مرات عده اقتلاع المستوطنون شتلات زيتون
زرعها عايد غفري في ارضه في قريه سنجل
الواقعه شمال رام الله لكنه الان يخشى ان
يصحو ذات يوم ليجد ارضه وقد سطى عليها
المستوطنون بالكامل لاسيما انها محاصره
ببعر استيطانيه تتوسع من جميع الجهات
الارض
هي هويتنا انتماءنا فبتش اصعب من لحظه انك
تيجي على ارضك ويوقف مستوطن جاي من
اثيوبيا بحمايه دوله كامله يطردك منها
ويوقف فيها
تسع بؤر استيطانيه عشوائيه اقرت الحكومه
المصغره في اسرائيل اطفاء الشرعيه
القانونيه عليها وهي تتوزع على معظم
محافظات الضفه الغربيه المحتله ويعني ذلك
انها ستلتهم مزيدا من اراضي الفلسطينيين
المتوجسين من خطه ضم هادئ بدات تنفذ نحن
رحبنا بردود الفعل
الدوليه حول ادانه هذه القرارات لكن للاسف
هذه الردود لم ترتقي لمستوى هذه الجريمه
يشكل المستوطنون 15% من سكان الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وتسعه في المئه من مجمل
سكان اسرائيل وهو امر لا يقوض براي البعض
رؤيه الدولتين فحسب بل يغيروا هويه
اسرائيل كدوله يهوديه
واحده ثنائيه القوميه هنالك نظام اسرائيلي
واحد مع هيمنه يهوديه بين النهر والبحر
لكن دون اغلبيه يهوديه وفي داخل الضفه
الغربيه تمت نظام فصل عنصري
وفي جعبه حكومه اليمين مخطط لتسريع بناء
الاف الوحدات الاستيطانيه الجديده واحلال
القانون الاسرائيلي على المستوطنات وربطها
بشبكه انفاق وجسور وشوارع مع مدن
اسرائيليه كبرى وهي استراتيجيه تحث
اسرائيل الخطى فيها لتنفيذ الضم الفعلي
ومحو الخط الاخضر الفاصل بينما استولت
عليه من اراضي الفلسطينيين بعد النكبه وما
احتلته في النكسه
في حكومه يشكل عرب الاستيطان قاعدتها
الاساسيه فان البناء في المستوطنات سينمو
ويتمدد لكنه يبقى سلاحا ذا حدين فالتوسع
الاستيطاني شرط اساسي لاستقرار التوليفه
الحاكمه لكنه ايضا قد يكون سببا لصدام
محتمل مع الاداره الامريكيه ليسك الرمى
الجزيره شمال القدس المحتله